[Music]
this installation is called neighbor
jiran jiran is a malay word for neighbor
actually so
i would love to say that it's an artwork
but um it's actually more functional
than that it's a type of beehive okay
when you relocate bees from
certain areas
the plants will get affected so
ecosystems get affected yes relocating
bees instead of smoking them to kill
them is a better method so i was
exploring the issue of like instead of
relocating bees you have bee hives
and have beekeepers relocate the bees
into
this portable bee system
and then
that can actually warn people that hey
there's a beehive here stay away from it
so it changes color when
it at a certain temperature so when the
bees vibrate their wings it goes up to
about 33 degrees and this will actually
change color according to the
temperature originally it's orange like
this over here and then it will
eventually turn yellow
[Music]
back then we used to look at design in a
way whereby it's just about posters
about advertisements and all that but
now design has evolved into a way where
it's a form of thinking the meaning
behind design evolved into something
different yeah
[Music]